and by the way congrats to Alec Baldwin
that just got ruled an accident it did
it did when recently I thought they said
that he had to have pulled the trigger
he did accidentally
but he lied and he said he didn't pull
the trigger
people get nervous Taryn Butler from
Taran tactical yeah what does this say
here medical investigator rules Baldwin
set shooting an accident well of course
he's not trying to kill that lady in
front of everybody I understand why they
said but that doesn't mean he wasn't
negligible just because it was an
accident what did the guy from Taran
tactical say it's impossible for that
gun to shoot he showed me the gun I had
a video of it I was like I don't want to
start trouble and release this but in
the video he has the gun not the actual
gun but the same model gun yeah and he's
showing how the action on this works and
he's like it's not possible for the
hammer to go forward and just
accidentally fire and he like [__] it
back and shows how it works he's like
you have to engage the